foreign
let's roll out to Princeton New Jersey
and talk to you the Great and Powerful
Conrad what's up Conrad
hey Dr John what up
uh just rocking on to the Breaking Dawn
yeah yeah what's up man how we doing
I'm doing all right all right let's
let's get to it dude we're not gonna
help uh so I'm really looking about how
do I go about getting my friends back
together or just to figure out how to
navigate Our Lives moving forward I've
had the same Core group of friends for
the last 15 20 years and uh I love them
all they're all amazing folks but uh the
past few years there's been like a rift
in the group and it all really came to a
head a week ago I was getting everyone
together just wanted to treat everybody
to dinner and you know have a good time
with everybody and it was made clear
that uh some folks didn't want to be
there they just flat out didn't want to
be there if certain folks were were
coming along
um so there's this huge Rift between
everyone uh I'm still friends with
everyone but it sort of put me in the
middle of things so I really want to
respect my friends and their wishes to
sort of grow as people but uh respect
the other folks involved at the same
time and I'm really struggling with it
yeah man how old are you
uh 30 this year this year
well congratulations you're almost dead
now because you're really old just
kidding
um uh I was gonna lay it out it's hard
man but this is how it happens
is that happens
there's friendships that you look back
on that mean everything and we have 10
years 15 years 20 years of history and
we did everything together
and they're gone
or one friend hooks up with somebody
else's wife or one friend gets divorced
or one friend you find out abuse their
kid or one friend passes away one friend
moves
and the world of trying to hold it all
together as a 30 year old becomes really
hard if you've ever listened to this
show I'm always talking about how hard
it's the worst having kids I mean having
kids having kids is awesome making
friends at 35.
I don't do enough job I don't do a good
enough job talking to how heartbreaking
it is when your friendships change at
30.
yeah it's sort of I'm because I still
talk to everyone and it was like you
know just this week we saw some folks
and they were like oh do you still talk
to someone so and it's like I'm in this
weird position because it's like yeah we
had dinner a couple nights ago but
they're just not talking to you okay why
is that a weird why is that a weird
position for you
laughs
you know it's because it sounds like you
have have positioned yourself as The
Wedding Planner like a JLo movie and
you're like it's your job to make sure
everybody's do it
and it's your job to love well and be
honest with people and to allow yourself
to be loved and so if they have Rifts
cool man I'm still gonna hang out
and if they ever put you in a position
to say hey if you're with them you're
not with me
then you got a choice to make
I mean luckily I have
um a good friend of mine when we were
planning this whole thing he said listen
um I just want to be you know upfront
with you I'm sort of grown as a person I
really don't want to you know hang out
with these folks anymore it's not my cup
of tea I'm not going to tell you who to
hang out with
um and like I appreciated him being so
upfront with it but it's like it's when
Friends start asking about oh what about
this person what about this person and
it's like you know dude
you know I should just be honest with
them and tell them
that's not your story to tell I would
just saying yeah I would say that's the
part I'm struggling with yeah they
didn't make it
yeah
like you don't have to get an
explanation
oh it's you're right it is rough because
it's like you know it's it's not the
whole group it's like you know a couple
folks and then everybody else that's
right and it's just I feel like I was
always like include folks and bring them
into the fold but now that it's like
this this distinct division
um but you're not you're not you're not
bringing people into the fold you're
trying to
you're they're trying to leave and
you're trying to force them to stay
that's different there's something about
including people who are on the margins
people who are on the outside people
that you think would be great in the
Gang
there's another thing when people in the
gang are like hey it's run its course
for me I'm out and you're like no no you
gotta stay you gotta stay you got you
gotta like we're all gonna
that's a different story that's you
propping up your picture of what this is
supposed to look like not honoring the
person on the margins
yeah I realize that sucks the way I just
said that no no no you're right it's
like
um I love them and I care about them and
I need to honor their Wishes the fact
that they want to grow and yeah as they
think that this guy just sucks right
it's not even about growth I don't like
that dude he always gets drunk and acts
like an idiot or it always hits on my
wife or whatever it's it's rough yeah
um it's really respecting them and
respecting their Journey with it
um
additional like bad blood there's no
like somebody swept with somebody's wife
or something like that but but you know
people growing as people and it's like
I guess it's coming to terms with the
idea that I had for the future and like
you know oh he's got you know work
together and go through like all right
having kids and doing all that and like
sort of have those people going through
it with you and accepting the idea that
that picture that I built for myself is
a little different now and that you know
people are changing and I can't control
that
one of my
one of my favorite people I've ever had
the opportunity to be friends with
um
he was in my wedding I was I
participated in his
um
I had a bad situation A housing
situation and I moved into his kitchen
literally he got rid of his kitchen
table and moved my bed into his kitchen
table in his kitchen
uh he's an amazing guy
and we went to We Were Young
Knuckleheads we went to Blink 182
concert
well years ago years ago
and then I went again recently
and I texted him a picture
said man I missed this and he goes man
me too that was that was those are good
times
and if I tell you what if I called him
and said I really need some help he
would be here in no time
because I love him he loves me he loves
my family he's friends with my wife I I
love his wife we're connected we always
will be but it's different now
he's an executive in some big fancy
company we live 17 hours away by car I
am a YouTuber for God's sake like right
so it happened
and if I could do anything to flip that
I would
because I missed the guy in my life
he's one of the greatest friends a guy
could have
and
I'm so excited for his professional
opportunities and for him and his family
and all the things and I know he has the
same for me and so it's just making
peace and grieving what was and making
peace with what is
and then I've got to do the hard scary
work of making friends in my local
community and that's terrible
but here we are right and that's just
one dude man there's like multiple guys
that like remember when remember when
Remember When
and here we are
and I wish it wasn't right around 30
when it all happens but that's a pretty
common time for people to have their
first kid people have their first
breakup people to be like hey am I
drinking anymore whatever the thing is I
don't go to church anymore I do go to
church I'm super Jesus freak whatever
the thing is
it just happens around this time
oh man nobody really talks about it
but well they don't talk about this like
hey things will change I appreciate you
calling here's what I would tell you to
do next time somebody and and Bravo to
him for Having the courage to set a
boundary right okay man I'm just um if
that guy's gonna be here I'm just gonna
bail that's cool you'll have a great
time Bravo to him
for not being a drama queen about it not
not causing a bunch of if he comes I'm
out and if you choose him he didn't do
that he acted like a grown-up right so
Bravo to him and
Bravo for you for respecting him and I
want you to when that happens
literally it's gonna sound cheesy put
your hand on your body where you feel it
is it in your chest is it in your
shoulders like when your body's like hey
I'm not gonna make it and you think of
that room and only 80 of the gang is
there right
feel that for a second and be like man I
wish everybody would be there it sucks
and then you blow it out and you put
your hand on your chest and you say cool
I'm proud of you for making making a
decision and I'm gonna go ahead with a
party I'm gonna do what I'm gonna do
that's the best you can do and if
somebody says hey have you seen
so-and-so like yeah we grabbed dinner
the other day
oh really why aren't they here I didn't
want to make it they couldn't make it
better things going on that's all you
got to do
you don't got to tell other people's
stories
but it's mostly you come into terms with
people have the right to come and go and
they will come and go in your life and
it hurts and it's hard and it's
completely normal
and the one thing you can control is I
am going to be a person that surrounds
myself with friends and Community it's
kind of I'm going to be I'm gonna have
people
even when I'm tired even when I don't
want to I'm gonna have people
I'm proud of you brother thanks for
calling man
and thanks for reminding me I need to
talk more about
that 28 to 33 year old season when
everybody kind of starts splintering and
moving on and there's that sense of loss
and hey let's keep the text threads
going and the memes going
but it's all just not the same
find some new Buddies to invite into the
fold and make sure you stay connected to
the guy that stepped out
sorry the pictures are changing man
as Blink-182 said
I guess this is growing up